brad sham has been calling Dallas
Cowboys football for forever and a day
and we are thrilled to have here back on
the Rich Eisen show the voice of the
Dallas Cowboys in his 39th season on the
Dallas Cowboys radio network he's Brad
sham how you been Brad Goodrich how are
you I am doing just fine let's get right
into it
what are the key lies coming here you're
either so let's let's start with the
basics
what do you think is the state of the
Dallas Cowboys right now well it's good
right now you know in at 10:30 tonight
Central Time it could be a lot better
there there a little bit of a mess right
at the moment the and and I think
everybody's culpable I don't think you
can hit an unexpected ditch like this
without in fact there are four people
who I hold completely blameless LP
lattice are the long snapper and Chris
Jones the punter and Dan Bailey the
kicker because they have been absolutely
perfect in their jobs and Shawn Lee who
has not been on the field the last three
weeks well is he going to be on the
field tonight I don't think so
it could change but they were iffy
enough during the week and if he doesn't
play tonight and you've got because this
is their week after Thanksgiving so now
you have the mini by and by next week it
would be a full month since he last
played and for the hamstring that he's
dealing with that would probably be best
so my guess is that he won't but that
the last time I talked to anybody about
it was yesterday morning so it's
possible something could change for
tonight it would surprise me why is
Shawn Lee that all-important jenga piece
for this town I think that part of the
that's part of the place that the
defensive coaching staff is culpable I
mean he's a great player and they don't
have anybody even remotely like him but
he can't be I mean he just can't be that
he cannot be that irreplaceable
you could lose but to be non-competitive
for three consecutive
in halves doesn't make any sense some of
it it's a it's like most of the stuff
that happens in football rich and you
know it it's it's twined together so
some of it is now their depth is less
than they thought it would be because of
preseason and training camp injuries to
three rookie defensive back so they
drafted who all made the team they
thought they were all going to play one
of them is going to start tonight and
it's going to be his first NFL start and
cheeto Rozier and that they didn't bring
several guys back because they were
older players and they thought that it
was not the best football economics okay
well you missed them and that doesn't
mean it wasn't the right decision at the
time but you missed them on the field
and then the coaching staff just has to
figure out ways to be more productive
than they've been and theirs so that's
why I say everybody's culpable Brad sham
voiced the Cowboys here on the Rich
Eisen show and in terms of that my
colleague at the NFL media group Ian
Rapoport reported this past week that
cowboy players are upset over the game
planning and certainly the in game
planning and in terms of the the fact
that offensive players are calling out
blitz schemes before they're actually
run and they're right almost every time
are are you hearing the same thing Brad
uh and not as much as he is and I don't
know how many of how many players he's
talking to and but I I think that one of
the signs that things are going bad is
when you have players look up and say
hey it's his fault but but they have to
look at everything when you had when
you've had three second halves like
they've had it's not a secret that Rod
Marinelli doesn't like the Blitz
his philosophy going all the way back to
when he started coaching is that if you
blitz some worse there's a hole back
there somewhere a good quarterback is
going to find it so you got to get where
you're going with four guys and they've
done I believe me an exhaustive study of
the last three games especially and when
they
giving up the chunk plays they gave up
they gave up an uncommon number to the
Los Angeles chargers and they have tried
to figure out what defenses they were
playing so they don't play those
defenses making some lineup changes and
so I think that you know there may be
some of that going on but I it's always
a little bit of a caution sign for me
when when you hear someone who is never
around the team quoting players as as
calling out coaches is some of that
probably true yeah I think they're
probably a little disgruntled but the
best thing those guys can do is look in
the mirror and see if they've executed
what they're doing well and if they're
doing the best they can then there will
be changes made above them but that's
not their concern right now well in
terms of that do you think Jason Garrett
is coaching for his job over the last
five weeks right now I don't I think
that I think that I could see some staff
changes coming but right now I don't
think that rich it's the same staff that
was 13 and 3 last year it's the same
staff with a change or two that was 12
and for two years before that so they
didn't all of a sudden get stupid the
team's different because the players are
different now you have to coach
different players differently you can't
coach them the same way you coached last
year's team but the same coaches have
been successful before they're not doing
a good enough job so far in the last
three weeks I mean they're five and six
that means they were five and three so
so either it's a little more complicated
than a tweet can Reluctant can reveal or
they all suddenly went brain-dead in a
three-week period I got a little trouble
with that theory
Brad sham voiced the Dallas Cowboys here
on the Rich Eisen show is Dez hurt he
just looked different he looks like he
can't win certain one-on-one battles
50/50 balls or more like 60/40 balls or
70/30 balls now I don't think he's her
right eye I do think that the there's
there's not a try harder guy on the tee
I think but this is my personal opinion
no doctor or coaches told me this but
just watching him I think that the leg
injuries various kinds hamstring knee
various kinds of foot leg injuries that
he's had over the last few years may
have taken some of his explosiveness
from him some of the leaping ability and
so there again it's incumbent on him and
the coaching staff to find different
kinds of routes there's nothing wrong
with him running as each slant some of
those one-on-one matchups he's having a
little trouble with so it's up to the
coaching staff to try to put him in the
best possible position to be successful
and how ticked off is Gerry Papa ticked
off do you know um he's picked off but
but he he's he's got more than his
football team that he's a little ticked
off right I know that well I mean in the
fact that the football team is
struggling his world right now yeah
that's that's the point you know I mean
it just seems like we this is the the
shots that we've been seeing on national
television of zooming in on him just I
think pondering what could have been
this season with him having his jacket
in his bust and his ring now yeah but he
knows but maybe the ponderings
were incorrect I mean usually what
happened my experience is it usually was
what happens when the media gets down on
a player or coaching staff or team first
of all the the team coaching staff and
administration is several steps ahead of
them and and also a lot of times when
someone says this is going to be really
good and it turns out not to be really
good and that makes the person who said
it was going to be look bad and the the
people who say that publicly don't
usually like that so there's got to be a
head role somewhere
so maybe the team was overestimated I
really think that one of the big
problems is they don't have enough depth
to overcome the wrong injuries very few
teams do
and and they didn't have a lot of
they've about four players that they
counted on really being something
couldn't contribute for most of the
first half of the year because of
training camp injuries that took them
out for a for a long period of time but
they they still should be more
competitive than they are now and and
they might yet be so we'll see I'll just
I will say this
they had that blowout game in Denver in
week two and that was not just the
second half that was a total disaster
from get enough I'm not sure somebody
didn't get hurt getting off the bus my
experience is a good team a really good
contending team never has a game like
that and that was a red flag to me and
then you know okay looks like they can
compete and and then they've had things
happen I mean you can break these three
losses down the Atlanta game happened
because they had past protection
problems and the coaching staff by its
own admission by the way did not react
well enough or quickly enough and then
things kind of snowballed but the the
reason it can't be an excuse is that the
team they're playing tonight has the
same record and they've had worse injury
problems Washington has placed eight
players and I might be conservative by
one or two
Washington's put eight players who
played either started or were
significant rotation players on both
sides of the ball on injured reserve
since they last played the Cowboys four
weeks ago it's unbelievable and then
obviously Zeke was the big difference
maker on the last time and they have I
frankly thought that that would be it
would be bad you lose one of the best
players that you're not as good I didn't
think it would be crippling and that's
the way their offense is set up maybe it
was a couple more minutes left with Brad
sham voices the Cowboys where is Zeki
that's all I don't know I don't know not
my week to watch him I think he's out of
the country somewhere he still is out of
the country I think though and then is
there any other time in cowboy history
with you
a team that this reminds you of that
this type of crossroads remind you of
well sure I mean look this last three
weeks have been a big surprise because
it looked like they were pretty good but
you know at Landry's last team was three
and thirteen that was the worst football
team I've seen in 39 years and then the
next year Jimmy Johnson's first one was
one in 15 and Dave Campo had three five
and eleven teams and they lost the first
ever game the Houston Texans ever played
that hadn't happened since 1960 with the
Minnesota Vikings and they lost a game
to the Rams in 2000 and I want to say
eight when Romo was hurt and Brad
Johnson quarterback him and the Rams
hadn't scored an offensive touchdown in
the first half all year and they scored
three in the first quarter and what yeah
oh yeah this is just this is just you
know bad football we'll all survive yeah
I know
you're naming some pretty low moments
right there hey write 39 years I'm lucky
to have some high moments if you don't
suffer you don't know when you're
celebrating well I think it wasn't
Denzel Washington who came on our show
Chris Brockman he's a big Cowboy fan
Brad he said you can't he can't have a
testimony without a test is what he said
there you go it's exactly right one he
dropped those rock I don't know what
will happen by the end of the year right
now I can't say anything convincing to
either you or me that they're going to
win again this year because I haven't
seen it for a month but they might and I
know screwy things happen all the time
and I know they've got some guys who are
better players they've been playing than
they've been playing so I read on
Twitter today someone locally said with
the Cowboys lose tonight than their
season's over and really because I'm
supposed to be in New Jersey next take
you watching Geno Smith play yeah I
think I'm going so I don't think the
season is going to be over it's that it
means they're not going to be ten and
six at best but there's a lot of
interesting stuff still that happens
Brad always love chatting really
appreciate your call the seats not talk
to you see you tonight
you got it that's Brad Chambliss the
Cowboys on Twitter at Boys
underscore VLX the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience